[Music]
Salvatore Conroy alpha tan jaimé okay
jaimé and Alicia tribunal a new Kindle
each other they make so you know oh my
god turn to go to the line and then
define true
Hotel paeonia washes burrata - Jean Todt
anthony hi i'm anthony oh of atomic nice
in Kenosha Hama Kayoko Cola so tiresome
Julia but it also allows it is our
method oh yeah
father out universe Machado yo [ __ ]
pretty fatty up at home you she likes it
hope so you know alabaster trail your
your pythons I know my calories yes how
y'all are you yeah that's why I see two
types evil doesn't son can see it's a
tall with a dull fire you need yoga City
of God role you're a simple color your
healing yoga whatever fashion which is
like a fortune yes is profile it social
you got tremendous even you should know
you're tired but yet paneling ways on
fasting the Roger with cottage cheese
nama higher utilization Shanghai
burritos esta la mama de la Mercado
Bishop Alvaro far apart another protein
saliva highly by Josephine Suzuki almost
like a motivating de and by her father
your jacket
Panther Party that generally I got
myself a TV channel maybe open a new
Hydra panting audience in the loss in
fact that is your protein powder water
humanity knows that song from part a
year on Nikita singer welcome to eternal
darkness
sangeun tony angelo gigolo Joe modest
iguana the only RTR woman to others from
physicians under the motto unity come
into the room walk the mercial ego mean
to the wrong flower woman they are trans
and I usually don't transfer just you
don't know your way yeah what the hood I
don't kiss you do is ask
[Music]
a two hour boat ride off the coast of
Colombia is an island the most densely
populated island on earth
[Music]
santa cruz del is latte consists of more
than 1,200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan on the
island is a school that runs up to the
tenth grade two shops and one restaurant
there is nurse steady supply of water
and a Seoul generator that only runs for
five hours per day there are no police
but there isn't much need for them as
everyone on the island knows each other
a hundred and fifty years ago the island
was primarily uninhabited and was
sometimes used by local fishermen as a
place to rest and take shelter during
storms gradually some fishermen came to
build their homes here these were the
grandparents and great-grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room
[Music]
pardon me professor maybe you can help
me out here is this word pronounced cash
or cash a cash appreciate it doc you see
when jock Bailey pronounces a word he
pronounces it right he can pronounce
this thing it's my Ragan he can
pronounce this thing
Sharon Ginetta he even pronounces words
that don't make a lick of sense albumen
and when you're that damn good with
words sooner or later someone's gonna
pay you to say hi dr. Bailey this is
jock Bailey the official pronounce er of
the National Spelling Bee Luxembourg L u
XE
[Music]
Galya sherbet Giro
GIF before jocks days is the world's
foremost pronounce our persnickety words
he began a spelling career on the other
side of the microphone jock was a
competitive speller in 1980 he found
himself in the finals of the Scripps
National Spelling Bee his word aloo cube
rate so he said elu CU b ra t and it
means to burn the midnight oil to study
all night and with those 10 letters
jock became a champion 23 years later
danke to Luke you braided all the way to
the Big Show propio phenom Roquefort
pyroclastic can I please a definition
but sometimes even Chuck's meticulous
pronunciations don't tell the whole
story English words are not always
spelled as they sound one thing that
makes English words really hard to spell
is the schwa the schwa is that uh like
in butter or unutterable the y and
syringe the a in balloon the Owen
freedom they all sound the same spoken
out loud a spellers nightmare
the longer and weirder a word is the
easier it is to spell take take the
state fish of hawaii but homo homo no ko
well the humuhumunukunukuapua'a that's
an easy word to spell it's just long
it's a weird word and weird things stand
out and are easier to remember oh and oh
and ASI a parent in Asia
correct for a man with perhaps the most
legitimate claim is the authority on
pronunciation jock takes a rather
agnostic approach to the right and wrong
ways to say things a lot of people are
kind of amazed that I know how to
pronounce all these words but I don't I
read them from the dictionary
well how does the dictionary know how to
pronounce a word because they go out
there and listen to native speakers if
there are a whole bunch of people who
pronounce that word a certain way that
makes it a correct pronunciation people
who have very strong opinions that
there's an incorrect way to pronounce a
word but it's like saying that dog
barked wrong that's
Bart well the dog gets to decide thanks
John I reckon you got more wisdom that
all the books in the library in a world
where cat videos and memes rule the
beach one media company will rise above
the noise this is great big story okay
right that's great thank you got it yeah
that's great cool
you can stop speaking like that now bye
what do you mean this is how I always
speak hey my name is red pepper I'm a
voice-over artist in the UK odd voiced
hundreds of movie trailers men in black
saving the earth from the scum of the
universe leveraged project Armageddon
Space Jam
mr. Bean's Holiday so many forget half
of them to be honest with you I started
doing television adverts animations
audiobooks I do a lot of video games as
well a lot of them are sound effects of
ghouls in the background mr. bean when I
first started doing movie trailers there
was only that was fun one man coming
soon to a cinema near you
sometimes I do romantic movies in a
sleepy town sometimes I'm doing hora
don't answer the door you gotta use your
voice you got a reason sometimes and you
gotta take it to the depths very
occasionally I get recognized but
generally no but at the time I do get
recognized phone goes off in the Train
guaranteed hello and people look up from
behind the newspapers the way I had got
into being a voice artist was kind of
strange are used to drive trains on the
London Underground one morning I was
making my announcements on sessions
Harold
a television executive was a passenger
on my train he got off of the next stop
ran up to my cab
they exchanged details and uh the rest
is history I've had some strange
experiences as a police artist I was
doing a trailer for Jurassic Park the
lost world Steven Spielberg movie and
kindly they chose me to do the voice in
the UK and something is coming
something big as I said that a voice in
my headphones said wow that's a great
voice and I didn't recognize it with
Steven Spielberg he was listening in
from the state's into London will I
swore I said who that is that everybody
went crazy in the studio
no Spielberg oh sorry I appreciate what
I do I'm still meticulous about what I
do I'm so proud of what I do
I really don't look at it as a job I'm
having fun it really is a cool job it's
got to be up there with one of the
coolest jobs on the planet right you got
it
true I'm out of here oh that's a wrap
when I was a kid I always played with
Legos I built cars planes motorbikes now
I built an arm
[Music]
meet David Aguilar my name is David
Aguilar
I am from Andorra and I'm 18 years old
when David was born his right arm hadn't
fully developed this is the my right arm
growing up it was quite annoying because
I received a lot of commentaries like oh
you don't have a hand or something like
that and while some would say this as a
disadvantage David is just a regular kid
he likes EDM he goes by the name hand
solo get it he has an embarrassing dad
he goes to school this is my school and
he can open doors with his Lego arm so
cool growing up he was obsessed with
Lego so much so he wanted to make it a
part of him literally I build my first
prosthetic arm when I was 9 years old
and I builded I run my hand it started
being a boat unfortunately the Lego
bricks weren't strong enough and it
wasn't for another nine years - he would
try again this is mk1 this is LEGO
Technic it's like the sophisticated part
of Lego I can do push ups with this
thing so it's quite strong when I first
build the arm and it was fully
functional I went to the mirror and I
was like oh that model the mk1 only took
five days to build of course like any
good adventure he got straight to work
on an upgrade and this is mk2 it has a
battery that works like a biceps and it
has this fishing cable that ties up in
here when I fix this to my shoulder I
can do this and the arm closes I can
stop in the middle and move it by myself
when I first brought this they were all
really amazed because how can somebody
create a hand out of Legos I was a
normal guy and when I build the yarn
everyone was like you're awesome you're
you're really smart they told me they
are really proud to be to be my friends
it's amazing
[Music]